take risks
i was having a call with a friend of
mine earlier today and she was looking
at my youtube videos and she said
evan i love the videos they're coming
along really well you have a lot more
passion
there's a lot more engagement this is
great but i want you to do
something different and i want you to
take more risks
i said well come on i've got the raw
series i've got my new
evans condos series i've got a whole
bunch of different stuff happening
no no i want you to take risks i want
you to do something totally different
outside your comfort zone
take a chance on something and i'm
always up for a challenge so what i want
to do is throw it out to you guys
youtube audience come up with an idea
you let me know what you want to see me
do
some kind of risk something different
than what you're normally seeing me do
my advice on something is fine but in a
different setting i don't know
give me something creative and if i like
it i just might do it
thanks for your help guys
you